wir schneiden jetzt johannes bernd wenn
du weißt was du dabei beachten muss
lerntest du nämlich viel längeres mit
dickeren und größeren er zwischen den
weißen und den roten johannisbeeren und
den schwarzen johannisbeeren gibt es
einen großen unterschied deswegen zeige
ich euch jetzt erstmal die technik für
die roten und die weißen johannisbeeren
sowie dieses schätzchen hier und dann
zeige ich euch danach die technik für
die schwarzen johannisbeeren
aber ganz egal welche farbe deiner
johannes bern haben der beste zeitpunkt
um die zu schneiden ist im winter bevor
die richtig austreiben und ihre kraft in
die triebe stecken ich habe jetzt mal
ein weißes tuch hinter die
johannisbeeren gehängt damit wir den
stärkeren kontrast haben und ihr die
einzelnen betriebe besser erkennen
können was man über rote und weiße
johannisbeeren wissen sollte ist dass
sie vor allem an den zwei- und
dreijährigen trieben tragen
das ist bei den schwarzen johannisbeeren
anlass das erzähle ich euch gleich noch
das heißt wenn wir die pflanzen
schneiden dann wollen wir dass wir gute
zwei bis dreijährige triebe haben auch
noch ein vierjähriges tripa und
natürlich den nachschub für das nächste
jahr also wir brauchen auch einjährige
triebe aber der fokus liegt bei den
roten und weißen johannes bern auf den
zwei- bis dreijährigen trieben weil die
die meisten und besten früchte abwerfen
ja woran erkennen wir jetzt welche
triebe alt sind und welche nicht die
älteren sind natürlich dicker sie sind
dunkler oft auch ein bisschen grün
angelaufen schon ein paar flecken oder
ein paar algen angesetzt und da kannst
du eigentlich ganz gut erkennen welche
triebe alt sind und welche nicht das
hier ist jetzt zum beispiel ein
vierjähriger trieb hier siehst du einen
3 jährigen trieb das ist ein
zweijähriger trieb und die einjährigen
triebe sind ganz hell und man erkennt
schon welches die älteren und welches
die in ihren triebe sind es ist so dass
je älter die triebe werden desto
schlechter wird die fruchtqualität also
die trauben werden kürzer es gibt
weniger und kleinere bären und die
verkauften dann auch irgendwann wenn man
die alten triebe nicht ausnimmt soll
jetzt ist unser ziel dass wir unsere
pflanze erst mal so beschreiben dass sie
schön luftig ist also sc die zu dicht
aneinander wachsen oder die sich
überkreuzen die kommen auf jeden fall
raus so dass ich jetzt hier die pflanz
auf jeden fall gut aus lichte damit alle
triebe genug platz
und dann ist das ziel dass wir zwei
einjährige triebe haben also diese ganz
hellen triebe 22 jährige triebe 23
jährige triebe und 24 jährige triebe so
sollte deine johannisbeere am ende
aufgebaut sein wenn du den alten strauch
hat der schon richtig verholzt ist dann
würde ich zuerst die dickere äste
rausnehmen und nicht vor einem radikalen
schnitt zurückschrecken auch wenn es
vielleicht erst mal innerlich weh tut
aber am ende wirst du dabei eine bessere
ernte einfahren und wenn du ganz alte
verkaufshütte pflanzen hast dann lass
ein paar mehr einjährige triebe stehen
damit die pflanze sich verjüngen kann
[Musik]
hier kommen wir zu den schwarzen
johannisbeeren das ist noch eine ganz
junge pflanze dies noch nicht so hoch
aber ich glaube ich kann euch trotzdem
ganz gut demonstrieren worauf es ankommt
der unterschied zu den anderen
johannisbeeren ist dass die schwarze
johannisbeere vor allem an den
einjährigen trieben trägt das heißt die
schwarzen johannisbeeren schneidest du
sehr ähnlich aber du versuchst möglichst
viele einjährige triebe stehen zu lassen
also alle die sich nicht über kreuz nur
da irgendwie im weg sind und dafür
nimmst du mehr altes holz heraus ich
schneide jetzt hier diese beiden dicken
alten triebe aus die sich ja schon drei
oder vier jahre alt sind so dass die
einjährigen triebe richtig schön platz
haben
ich las beim johannes beschneiden immer
ein stummel über dem boden stehen damit
aus den augen die an dem stummel sind
neue triebe austreiben können und so
kann man sich dann neue ein ihre
getriebe von unten herauf hochziehen und
wenn du deine pflanzen noch nicht
gemacht hast dann kannst du das jetzt
auch machen ich verwende dafür am
liebsten holzhackschnitzel und verteilt
die in dem kreis um die pflanzen traurig
hält den boden schön feucht dass es auch
gerade bei stachelbeeren die
stachelbeere hast auch super wichtig
berlin ist sehr gerne ein bisschen
feuchter mögen und nicht so gut mit
trockenheit zurechtkommen und er
unterdrückt auch die gräser auf der
wiese und um deine pflanzen sie dass
deine pflanzen nicht so viel konkurrenz
haben aber ganz egal welche farbe deiner
johannisbeeren haben
wir ernten jetzt johannes b
[Musik]